I'm trying to get you to relax I can't
relax until I find my sister uh husband
I am NOT a charity case why you being I
figured it I'm not being secretive I'm
not I mean I'm done getting out there
again I can't tell them they'll tease me
about it or make me uncomfortable who's
the guy what is about what did he do is
he good enough for you which is great
that's what family's supposed to do but
for someone like me who's trying to get
back out there it can be jarring I think
you need an Anglo there could be any
color for me I don't care don't have to
be lyceum it
they could be Caucasian I've dated lots
of beautiful gorgeous minute why you
look like gorgeous man oh my god it's so
much work yeah I'm not you need you a
nice look I'm gonna do who's not gonna
take a long time getting ready you got
to stop with these fine little lollipops
honey don't listen you got to find you a
guy whose self-esteem ain't too high
because if he got a little low
self-esteem right he gonna always be on
his toes to keep toni braxton living
legend take it from me first of all I'm
an alpha woman oh that mean alphabet I'm
like a dude girl I don't know how to do
the sauce ups and make a guy Tony is
supposed to be a little damsel in
distress that show me how to do that
because I don't know I don't know how to
do nothing I mean look it's very
important for you to be damn some
distressful today you know you can't act
like you have it all the way together
right because and then like to fix
things and so if they feel like that
then it can't fix you up a little bit
we'll fix you up today like is now want
move on you can't be all enhanced around
black what no no won't dad okay dad like
they want that but they really don't
want dad let me help me yeah okay oh
okay so I'm you and you the guy oh my
god I can't get my TV work oh can you
help me fix my TV guys are like that
show baby I'll fix your TV and then you
make massive pork skins and y'all live
happy together after it's amazing
you